some things happened yesterday
some things were said
on the bright side though at least
Donald Trump is no longer the most
controversial candidate in the race I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from top 10 guy one
who says amazing how it has turned into
15 Jabs to flatten the curve that's true
so close it's probably it's it's
probably the case that we'll be done
after 15 though right there's no way
Lucy's going to pick up that football
again right right I'm sure just one more
just take one more folks you would have
known early on two years ago that so
much of the crazy covid guidance was
ridiculous if you had been able to talk
about it you know but unfortunately a
lot of the big tech companies clamped
down Love The Establishment media were
obviously pushing the covid narrative
that's why we need to be able to talk to
one another when you want to talk to
your friends and family you got to check
out pure talk right now go to
puretalk.com enter code Knowles there is
no reason to pay Verizon ATT or T-Mobile
over 80 bucks per month for wireless
Services when you can get the same
service on the same network with pure
talk for half the price with pure talk
you get talk text and data just as fast
for just 30 dollars per month those
other guys are making you pay for
thousands of retail stores you don't go
to perks you don't use and massive
profits to keep their shareholders happy
Pure Talk on the other hand wants to
keep you happy which is why they've
invested in a us-based customer service
team it's also why they give you so many
more data options why would they charge
you for data that you don't need I love
pure talk I did the switch I love
supporting better known us-based
companies that have my best interests at
heart
takes less than 10 minutes to switch
saves you a ton of I'm saving a ton of
money with my Pure Talk subscription go
to puretalk.com enter code Knowles save
50 off your first month that is
puretalk.com promo code nulls for 55 0
off your very first month anything
happen in the news yesterday
was there I don't know I was sort of
scrolling through and oh yes I saw the
Alex Jones interview
heard round the world I had a lot of
work that I was supposed to do yesterday
could not do any of it because I like so
many people was glued to my screen I
didn't even at first know where to find
this Alex Jones Show I just was blowing
up all of her social media Kanye West is
on Alex Jones saying all sorts of crazy
things and I so I found the link I think
on rumble or something
Kanye in his own words
I see good things about Hitler also the
Jew I love everyone and Jewish people
are not going to tell me you can love
um
you know us and you can love what we're
doing to you with the contracts and you
can love what we're you know what we're
pushing with the pornography but this
guy that
invented highways invented the very
microphone that I use as a musician you
can't say out loud that this person ever
did anything good and I'm done with that
I'm done with the classifications every
human being has something of value that
they brought to the table especially
Hitler how about that one Ari Emmanuel
how you like that one Hey Ron you're
going to do anything to fix Chicago even
like our truth the fact that African
Americans were in America before the
Pilgrims that truth is hidden that we
are actually the Native Americans or
some of us are native
so a couple of fact checks here uh the
black people were not in America before
the Pilgrims and are not they are not
the the Native Americans the real Native
Americans and also you you do not in
fact have to hand it to Hitler
you never actually have to hand it to
Hitler and this for those who are just
listening right now
and can't see it Kanye is wearing this
full kind of [ __ ]
suit and head mask thing so you can't
see his face throughout the interview
Alex Jones keeps saying is this really
even Kanye I'm talking to you it's an
amazing thing to watch Alex Jones be
made uncomfortable in an interview
because he he comes at and he says you
know well all those people are calling
you a Nazi and but you're not a Nazi and
Kanye says well sir you know so it
that was very very jarring it's why
everyone tuned in in the first place but
then
Kanye complicates
his Declaration of love for the Nazis by
declaring love for all sorts of other
people
I love the Zionist I love the people
that that blocked my bank account
because God runs the world and uses
everyone I do love Hitler I do love the
zionists I love everyone I love Jewish
people I love Jewish we're talking about
Stanley Kubrick but Jesus is King and I
love everyone this is Love's speech Ari
this is Love's speech in Jesus name the
real king of Israel Jesus Christ this is
lust Beach I love Jewish people
I love super models I love everyone
accordingly from all the way from the
balenciagas to the Hitler's let me tell
you a story hold on Sir okay to Arya
Manuel to Jamie dimon to the people who
I love all of those you love Mao Zedong
absolutely
clarify that you're saying you're like
christ-like you love everybody yeah you
love Jim Jones you love Jeffrey Dahmer
absolutely everything okay well let's
clarify it
so you would assume that when someone
says I love Hitler and I love the Nazis
that would be followed by and I hate the
Jews but Kanye follows it here by I love
the Jews I love the zionists I love
supermodels I love Mao Zedong I love Ari
Emmanuel I love Stalin I Love Lamp I
don't know I love I love all of these
things
but then he goes on and does seem to
have a special sort of ire for the Jews
and this is what led into
another episode of this three hour long
interview
that went viral as well when Kanye
pulled out an aquarium net and a bottle
of Yoo-hoo to do a sort of Carrot Top
prop comedy routine about
uh the Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
net net and Yoo-hoo
what we did is we brought Netanyahu with
us
I'm in the Twilight Zone right now
Netanyahu what do you have to say what
do you have to say to Alex Jones right
now Nick Fuentes and yay
it was bad it was bad attracting me
okay
I had no idea your voice is going to
sound like that Netanyahu
so you don't like Benjamin yet Yahoo
you get it it's a net and Yoo-hoo
and he's sitting there with Nick Fuentes
who is working on his campaign and who
was at that Trump dinner and caused all
the big stir and then
then however the interview took another
turn and specifically on the whole net
net and Yoo-hoo bit he takes it in this
very personal Direction
if I say something that's provocative
towards the Mossad is that misogynistic
hold on let's hear from netany
thanks a lot netting
back to you Alex uh please turn your
phone microphone around sir
I mean I'm definitely overwhelmed here
right now um infowars.com tomorrow's
news today
um listen all I'm trying to get through
here is I believe every group what's his
name to netten I dropped the uh the
Yahoo so we didn't have to I was tired
of picking up the Yahoo and The netting
so for now is just netting I know some
people call him BB no some of you call
them yeah Yahoo but we're gonna call him
netting
what you want then hey yay right after
this I'm gonna say you're crazy I'm
gonna take your family away from you
we're not done with you yet you cannot
cause free thought we have to control
the history books we have to control the
banks and we have to go and kill people
also we're in a better very high
so
at this point in the interview if you're
still watching you're starting to think
okay
something's gone even more off the rails
here than at other times in yay's public
career and then he takes it
all the way personal so it starts out
with Hitler and the Jews then it goes I
love everybody I love I love lamp I love
you know all the I love the Jews I don't
it's not just that I love Hitler I love
the Jews but really I don't like
Benjamin Netanyahu and Israel and but
really this is all about this personal
stuff my family my kids
my life and then and then he kind of
ditches the BB Netanyahu thing and just
gets right into his his personal family
problems
my security is the fact that I didn't
load up pornography last night and I
said this addiction is going to have to
flee from me you know this addiction
since I was five years old that is
destroyed my my mom and my dad's family
that destroyed my family like when I
take full accountability for the
destruction like of my marriage when I
when I I'll point at the Liberals and
say you took my wife from me you know
what took my life for me the fact that I
was married to this beautiful person but
it I felt like it wasn't enough I felt
like I still needed to look at
pornography and some way I'd say to her
we'll stop making these images stop
breaking the internet you know that
original term comes from my ex-wife
actually having a nude photo that I
didn't know about that someone used her
and put her on a magazine but there's
somewhere where she's like well if my
husband is looking at this I still want
to be like the girls that are doing this
and this becomes people reliving the
traumas pushing the addiction
so so this was the most amazing part of
the interview and nobody's talking about
it because he says look I blame the
Liberals for breaking up my family but
it wasn't the Liberals it was me but
Kanye doesn't blame the Liberals he
blames the Jews in other places for the
zionists or the whoever for breaking up
his family or Benjamin not Yahoo is
going to come and take his family but
then in this moment probably the most
Lucid moment of the interview he says
but it wasn't them
meaning the Liberals are or elsewhere he
said it's the Jews or what it was me it
was me because I looked at pornography
and I did it and and so I lost my family
there are three
defining struggles in Kanye West's
public career that we've seen the first
one is mental disorder meaning he's just
his mind just gets disordered and you
see he's talking about how black people
were here before the Native Americans or
something right you know among all the
other things he said he just said things
that are just so manifestly incoherent
and and uh
obviously not true
then there's performance art Kanye West
has always been this wild performance
artist George Bush doesn't like black
people Taylor Swift I'm going to take
your award from you and I'm not I'll let
you finish but Beyonce had the better
album you got to give this album to
Beyonce then he goes a step further he
says slavery was a choice right one of
the most shocking and offensive things
you can possibly say then he took it up
another level when he put the Maga hat
on wearing that Maga hat which this was
after the
media had called Trump the devil for
however long he says so that's the most
offensive provocative thing I can
possibly do you tell me I can't do it
that's what I'm going to do and then he
took it to its absolute perfect extreme
by saying I like Hitler I like Hitler is
the most shocking and offensive thing
you can possibly say in our culture
Hitler is synonymous with the devil in
our language that it's why he didn't get
the same reaction he says I love now I
love Stalin people can get away with
saying I love Mao I love Stalin well you
can hand it to them you can wear a shake
of orange or whatever
in our language Hitler is synonymous
with the devil in fact worse than the
devil because Hitler was incarnate the
devil's just a spirit Hitler was
incarnate and so you you see even taking
aside maybe Kanye hates the Jews maybe
Kanye's a Nazi whatever you just see
that as the extreme manifestation of
that kind of performance art and then
the third one which no one's talking
about is this guy just lost his whole
family and if you've ever known someone
who's gone through a divorce they go
kind of crazy most of the time and
especially if they've already got these
sort of underlying mental issues and
these underlying artistic issues where
you you were naturally drawn to these
extremes when something like that
happens people can just break and so
it's why I'm not going to make fun of
Kanye West it's why I'm not even going
to really engage too seriously in any of
the claims he's making whether it's
about you know Hitler or the black
Native Americans or Bibi Netanyahu I
mean when he was laughing manically with
the Yoo-hoo in one hand and the the net
in another
I just think it's a really cheap shot to
make fun of somebody or to castigate
somebody you know too too seriously and
he was just kicked off of Twitter
because he posted a star of David with a
swastika in the middle and people are
assuming this is just another
Declaration of his love for the Nazis
it's actually not that's a symbol of
What's called the realism movement
the raelian movement was this movement
from the 1970s
founded by a guy named Claude vorhillon
and I'll see if I yeah here so the
symbol is this this little pendant that
they would wear of the Star of David
with the the swastik in the middle but
it's this idea it's this kind of crazy
cult that believes that uh there are all
these aliens and that you get abducted
by aliens and that uh the word El hoim
Elohim you know the word for God is a
plural term which means those who came
from the sky and they would they would
wear these sort of extraterrestrial
symbols so anyway it's just obviously
all the symbol of disorder and what
should one do
one should
pray for Kanye probably not uh you know
probably not take this stuff
all that seriously I don't I don't think
he should be going on like TV to be
pontificating on these views he
he's always had those three problems
even the personal issues in his life
because he's he's cycled through so many
advisors constantly I personally am
friends with like three of communist
advisors going back 10 years and I don't
know Kanye West I've never met Kanye
West and so you think there are all
these these personal relationships he
lashed out in that interview against
Dave Chappelle for doing a comedy bit
about him Dave Chappelle was defending
Kanye in the comedy bit you know it's
just
if any one of these issues were going
off at a particular time it would be
dangerous but you've got the mental
disorder and you've got the performance
art and you've got the personal life all
kind of crashing around and so I say
probably should should pray for the guy
that's what I would do and I would
protect yourself and I would protect
your assets and what you've got and one
great way to do that is with Birch gold
right now text Knowles do 98 98 98 will
the lack of a red wave during the
midterms lead to more Reckless spending
by a more emboldened widen
Administration higher taxes deeper
inflation if you are unsure of how the
next two years will unfold or if you are
pretty sure because you see things going
in a bad Direction talk to Birch gold
group about protecting your savings with
gold
Birch gold makes it easy to convert your
IRA or 401K into an IRA and precious
metals so you can own gold and silver in
a tax sheltered account here is what you
need to do text nulls kwles to 98 98 98
to claim your free info kit on gold then
talk to one of their precious metals
Specialists they will hold your hand
through the entire process with an A
plus rating with the Better Business
Bureau thousands of happy customers and
almost 20 years of experience converting
IRAs and 401ks into precious metals IRAs
Birch gold can help protect your savings
too technology wlas to 98 98 98 and
protect yourself with gold today that is
Knolls to 98 98.98 speaking of
Balenciaga
I didn't let the Kardashians and Kanye
had a deal with Balenciaga and Kanye
actually I think that mask he was
wearing on the Alex Jones Show was from
Balenciaga oddly enough even though
we've been talking about this a few
times now over the past couple of weeks
there's this weird Balenciaga scandal
where they posted ads that were
evocative of child pornography and s m
and Satanism and all this kind of weird
stuff so it gets even weirder
one of my associate producers called my
attention to this there's another
Balenciaga child photo ad where it's a
kid wearing a Balenciaga kind of suit in
what's obviously a little kid's room but
then in the back
there's there's a little uh doll of a
devil there's that little weird s m doll
in in the front the shoes kind of look
like two little Red Devils looking out
at you but then this part is really
really strange there is caution tape
but instead of saying caution it says
Balenciaga but instead of saying
Balenciaga b-a-l-e-n-c-i-a-g
[Music]
it says b a a l e n
that is Bal that is
one of the most prominent demons ever
worshiped going back to antiquity
that's not just an accident someone had
that tape made up or someone at least
went on the computer and made it look
that way but probably it's a it's a
practical prop
this on top of the fact that when you
type Balenciaga Latin to English into
Google Translate
it translates that to do what you want
which is the first commandment of the
satanists again very strange because
those words don't mean anything in Latin
so and it does it just comes up as
gibberish until that you add that final
AGA and then it says do what you want
and then when you type in ball and siaga
into Google Translate b-a-a-l
it all of a sudden capitalizes the B it
says ball is the king and now you're
seeing ball referenced directly because
one thing that people have said is well
Michael Balenciaga is just a guy's last
name you say well yeah sure so then why
are we getting all these strange
renderings when you type it in
specifically into Google translate yeah
it's just a guy's last name I'm not
saying the company was founded as a an
homage to a ball or something like that
but why are you getting all this satanic
imagery and then why is the tape spelled
b-a-a-l why is it was ball right right
there obviously there's something going
on I don't I don't know I don't I don't
have an answer for that
but as we've said from the beginning
here
one strange occurrence maybe that's a
fluke two strange occurrences maybe
that's a coincidence
three four five
six
that's a pattern that you you cannot
deny and then the fact that there is
this Kardashian Kanye very close
relationship to Balenciaga while this
whole thing is blowing up is also
completely bizarre that alone is
completely bizarre Kim Kardashian is the
face of Balenciaga Kanye West continues
to wear Balenciaga clothing
what is it I don't know I don't know I'm
just pointing out really strange
coincidences speaking of a product by
the way
you know we we read ads for hair uh
Jeremy's razors not Harry's Razors
obviously we read the ads for Jeremy's
razors and it's uh a lot of people love
the commercial you know Jeremy getting
out with the supermodels and the McLaren
and everything it's flame throwers and
it's a very cool commercial a lot of
people though especially new daily wire
members who don't know the story of
Jeremy's razors
Jeremy's razors
it was entirely made to save my career
because people don't even know the
background the background was
I was on a show I was on the air and I
made this claim that men and women are
different this is a claim that now uh
you know there's a whole movie about it
actually but at the time
uh some
trollish type account maybe it was a
Democrat operative maybe not uh came out
and
started tagging my sponsors and said
Michael said this horrible thing this is
terrible he said men and women are
different you need to cancel your ads
from his show and Harry's Razors led a a
campaign to boycott my show to pull the
ads from my show to say there was a
values misalignment you know essentially
saying Michael Knowles and his listeners
are the worst people on Earth we don't
want their business and you really
shouldn't do business with them either
and so there was a potential run on my
show and when there's a run on your show
and you lose all your advertisers you
lose the show you can't you cannot float
that for for very long and so this was
an actual concerted effort to take out
my show and Jeremy and the daily wire
came in and said uh-uh we're not
tolerating that and they fought behind
the scenes for her and they said don't
you dare pull your ads well forget Aries
stupid Harry's but for to the rest of
the advertisers don't you dare pull your
ads don't you dare do this especially
publicly this is outrageous this is
we're going to stand behind not just me
but any conservative because you know
look I said the most basic thing you
possibly can men and women are different
so if they're going to kill my show for
that they're going to go after all of us
and then because Jeremy he's just got
something wrong in his head something I
don't know maybe he was born under a
weird star something in this man's head
he just he's like a dog with a bone
Jeremy decided to dedicate the next year
to creating an actual razor company to
go and Destroy Harry's it was just a
vindictive joke okay and so and they did
that and then coincidentally became this
great Razor Company well right now if
you go to jeremy'sraisers.com you can
get a wonderful bundle and all of this
to say you should go over there to
jeremiserazers.com and buy the bundle
not just for yourself but for your
friends it makes a great Christmas
present and it's just such a way to show
yeah man stand up for the conservatives
stand up for people who have common
sense stand up against these these
insane bullies who are trying to silence
you for saying perfectly ordinary things
that's how you do it I like to think
that my blank book was a little fun
stocking stuffer to to Stick it to the
Man you know reasons to vote for
Democrats well this is a much Fuller
version of that because it's saying no
we're going to build our own companies
even if we have to but we need your
support to do it so please uh please
head on over and do that and while
you're at it be sure to go check out
mizen and Maine right now go to mizzen
and maine.com use promo code Knowles
mizzen and Maine are the inventors of
the performance fabric dress shirt is
there anything worse than being
uncomfortable I don't think so missing
in Maine doesn't think so either that is
why they make the most lightweight
breathable and moisture wicking dress
shirts you can buy they're high
performance dress shirts are warm in
Winter and cool in summer think of their
clothing as your secret weapon for any
occasion I am confident if you give Miss
an remain a try you will never go back
to Conventional men's clothing again
missing in Maine's dress shirts are the
best dress shirts that you can possibly
pick up I just adore them one because
they feel so comfortable but two they
look really smart the style is just
really so much better than than what
you're seeing out there today it's just
just really really smart style okay
style matters a lot to me don't believe
me check out all the missing and Main
reviews and then check it out for
yourself look the best you can this
Christmas season go to visit maine.com
promo code Knowles kwles you'll get 35
off any regular order
of 125 bucks or more that is 35 off when
you go to m i z z e n a n d m a i n.com
promo code nulls we have all sorts of
products today you know products that we
sell at the daily wire for a products
that you know are wonderful advertisers
have but then there's some products that
I don't know I don't know that I can
quite get behind
Tampax so I've never I haven't used
Tampax myself uh you know I can't say
that I was a regular customer but Tampax
has a very strange advertising campaign
they launched this a couple of weeks ago
meant to get to it
fits in right now in the Christmas
shopping season
Tampax tweeted out
you're in their DMS we're in them we are
not the same
yeah I did I read that correctly
so I think obviously it's a it's like a
sex joke you know about
about the about women and about what
women use Tampax for
my first reaction was
why are tampons tweeting why do tampons
have to tweet because all brands have to
Tweet now and All Brands Market
themselves on this kind of edginess
right they you have to tweet to sell the
product and the way to get attention on
social media as I think we've all seen
in the last 24 hours is to consistently
go and say the edgiest things that you
possibly can and this is not a great
long-term strategy
the entire culture is incentivizing us
to do that ever more and more but as a
long-term strategy that's it's not
really smart I talked about this on the
Matt frad show the other day
Matt fradd said Michael you're a
Catholic but you're also a conservative
talking head and so does does your
Catholic obligation to be charitable and
not to you know constantly go out and
detract from everybody does that
conflict with your role as a as a
professional owner of the libs and I I
thought you know maybe sometimes I hope
it doesn't but I'm sure we all messed up
sometimes but I generally try not to
because
if you
if you stake your career or your brand
or your professional life I'm just
constantly being more and more offensive
more and more shocking more and more
edgy not only are you probably going to
flame out as happens to basically
everyone who attempts the strategy but
it's also going to lead you into saying
things
that you probably don't really believe
that you
probably don't really think are totally
true you'll you'll just be incentivized
to do that for shock value
which is not a good way to live and it
will end up depriving you of your
integrity and and of you know in in the
name of breaking through these uh
strictures and the censorship you're
going to end up saying things that you
don't think are true in the first place
speaking of weird sex stuff
headline
the weird sex stuff and dishonesty
headline out of the BBC
trans woman jailed for sex with 14 year
old girl
headline actually mean I'm going to
translate that headline
from woke politically correct dishonesty
into English
man arrested man jailed for raping child
that's what that really means I'm a
trans woman
jailed for sex with 14 year old girl
what do we call it when 25 year olds
have sex with 14 year olds do we call
that we just call that sex
no we usually call that rape that would
be statutory rape everywhere in the
United States or Britain or you know
anywhere in the Civilized world
and then what do we call a trans woman
in reality we call that a man but it
shows you the power of of language
which is a real hobby horse of mine but
you've got to constantly come back to it
because you
you think
because you are conscious and you read
the news and you know what's up and you
you get all of your information from
different sources you don't only believe
CNN you think that you can catch the
deception but you you can't none of us
can all the time because
so much of the leftist deception is
built into the very language that we use
when you use the phrase trans woman or
if you refer to a guy who thinks he's a
woman as she or even if you refer to a
guy who thinks that he's a woman with a
woman's name
you are
consciously or unconsciously accepting
the premises
a woman has a right to go into the
woman's bathroom
she has a right to go into the woman's
bathroom
Caitlyn has the right to go into the
woman's bathroom when you accept terms
like gay marriage which even people who
oppose gay marriage often will use the
term gay marriage you are accepting the
premise that gay marriage is just a it's
a type of marriage
you know you can have American marriage
or an Indian marriage or a gay marriage
but it's it's not the whole the whole
point of the debate is that gay marriage
is a contradiction in terms and it's
completely different intrinsically it
cannot be the same thing as marriage
we do this constantly the undocumented
workers undocumented Americans
undocumented Americans are just a type
of American except they're not they're
foreign Nationals they're they're not
Americans Justice involved youth that's
one of my favorite academic euphemisms
for for criminal children you know
criminal minors or justice-involved
person is used to refer to adults
whatever justice-involved persons are
they are not involved with Justice
they're criminals they're involved with
Injustice actually it's a total
deception so you've got to be aware of
even if you're reading this you say wait
something's clearly gone wrong here it's
not a trait you've got to translate it
in your head and say it in your head in
order to really appreciate this trans
women jailed for sex with 14 year old
girl no no
grown man rapes child that's what it is
it's gonna give it'll give even you a
different and more accurate picture
speaking of deception by the way
huge news story
the liver King
has been exposed as a fraud do you know
who the liver King is I didn't either
Brett Cooper actually turned me on to
him he's some social media phenomenon
where he's a super jacked guy who never
has a shirt on and he's always just
eating
organs of giant animals he'll sit there
I saw one video he said why would you
chew gum when you could eat lung and he
pulls off part of a cow lung and starts
chewing on it the whole idea was I don't
really do anything special I just eat
all these totally Primal kinds of foods
and that's how I got super jacked and
the guy was obviously on steroids and it
just came out that he's on steroids and
here's his apology
I'm making this video to apologize
because I [ __ ] up
because I'm embarrassed and ashamed
because I lied and I misled a lot of
people I've stated that this is a
complicated Topic at least to me it is
because before social media I was rich
and Anonymous and after social media I'm
still rich but no longer Anonymous and I
never expected this kind of exposure in
the public eye
it's been tricky as [ __ ] to navigate
well
clearly I did it wrong and I'm here now
to set the record straight
yes I've done steroids and yes I'm on
steroids monitored and managed by
trained hormone clinician
wow shocking none of us could ever see
this
no you can't
you can if you're not taken by this
constant push that is accelerated by
social media and by our pop culture and
our celebrity culture to just be more
and more outrageous more and more
shocking one Maxim that I often come
back to on this show is hey be normal
just be normal it's good to be normal
and so we're talking about at the top of
the show you don't have to hand it to
Hitler you don't actually you don't uh
the people are titillated by really
shocking statements and and it it gets
and shocking images and it gets people
to think wow maybe this thing that I
know is not possible or not true or
completely out of left field maybe it
really is true
usually it's not
usually things are are just a lot more
normal than all of that if generally
speaking you can just trust your
faculties of reason and your moral
conscience and the traditions in which
you have been raised generally speaking
those are going to be much better guides
to uh to your own life than you know
some some person making some insane sort
of claim whether it be about uh you know
the second world war or about uh how to
get really jacked eating cow lung or
something uh if if it's
if it seems too wild crazy singular to
be true it it probably is
this is in part why we are conservatives
because we understand that the old tried
and true stuff has a much better track
record than the modern Flights of Fancy
titillating though they may be last
Friday we launched a new series speaking
of the great traditions and the things
that have endured through all of time we
launched a great great new biblical
series with Dr Jordan B Peterson series
is called Exodus in it Jordan sits down
with other Scholars to read the book of
Exodus and to discuss what it means and
why it remains significant thousands of
years after it was written
Dennis brager Jonathan pajon many many
other people in there episodes one two
and three are available to stream right
now you have got to check out this
episode here's the trailer
so the Hebrews created history as we
know it
you don't get away with anything and so
you might think you can bend the fabric
of reality and that you can treat people
instrumentally and that you can bow to
the Tyrant and violate your conscience
without cost you will pay the piper it's
going to call you out of that slavery
into Freedom even if that pulls you into
the desert
and we're going to see that there's
something else going on here that is far
more Cosmic and deeper than what you can
imagine the highest
[Music]
Spirit to which we're beholden is
presented precisely as that spirit that
allies itself with the cause of Freedom
against tyranny I want villains to get
punished but do you want the villains to
learn before they have to pay the
ultimate price that's such a Christian
question
you have to be a member to watch so head
on over to dailywire.com subscribe to
become a member and watch Exodus today
and we have finally arrived at my
absolutely favorite time of the week
when I get to hear from all of you in
the mailbag
this mailbag is sponsored by if you're
talking to puretalk.com select a plan
enter code Knowles and get 50 off your
first month
first question
hi Michael Arun here I am an
astrophysicist which I mentioned for
context because you recently piqued my
curiosity when you mentioned that behind
the heliocentrism debate within the
Catholic Church during the 17th century
or deeper and more profound
philosophical and Theological issues I
was wondering if you could talk from
your perspective as a Catholic Christian
about what those philosophical issues
are and maybe also about what are the
philosophical and perhaps even
metaphysical implications of the
einsteinian view of the universe in
which there is no preferred Center to
the universe
thank you as always for your wisdom
a rune very very good question yes you
can see uh how misrepresented the
Catholic Church's position on science
has been when you look at the history of
these sorts of controversies one uh the
most prominent scientists ever have been
not only Catholic but in many cases have
been Catholic priests
father George lametris is the person who
first theorized the Big Bang
Catholic priest Gregor Mandel Catholic
priest the discoverer of mendelian
inheritance and genetics
a Copernicus was maybe a Catholic priest
though he that's a little bit unclear he
was at least a Catholic Canon
and many many others but but if you look
at say when Copernicus puts forward the
idea that the Earth revolves around the
Sun
he was not really persecuted for it uh
Galileo puts forward this idea and he he
was persecuted for it but not exactly
for for suggesting the idea it was more
for being just a huge jerk all the time
and and so when copernicus's book comes
out on the celestial spheres he there
there was a preface added to the book
that said that this is meant to
facilitate calculations but it's not
necessarily meant to be taken literally
Galileo comes out and not only proposes
his view as a literal view but he also
antagonizes the pope and members of the
clergy in the book and he has
simplicious in this dialogue meaning
simpleton though it's a reference to a
an interpreter and a commentator on
Aristotle but it's obviously meant to
suggest this person is a simpleton and
that represents
the Pope's view so he just was kind of a
jerk and he didn't play his cards really
straight either the reason I bring up
the word literal is because
the word literal is very confusing
especially in our day and age because
literal is supposed to mean not
figurative or not symbolic but literal
refers to letters which are signs and in
our day and age are symbols as well so
what does it even mean to to be literal
if you tell me
you mentioned Einstein's view of the
universe when when you tell me that
there is no Center to the universe or
we're in this kind of static you know
infinite sort of universe or any really
any modern scientific depiction of the
universe that you want and you tell me
that the Earth is on this little ball
circling this other little ball in a in
a galaxy in a in a galaxy cluster and
another galaxy cluster and Galaxy Super
cluster
I don't know what that means
if you tell me that man is the center of
the universe
I I do know what that means
and furthermore when you say man is the
center of the universe that more
accurately describes man's actual
position in the world because man is the
Nexus of the physical world and the
metaphysical world through his rational
soul man is the only being in this world
that that can be said of
animals are bodies and they have a soul
proper to their nature but they don't
have a rational Soul that's why we don't
put them on trial when a when a cat
scratches a human being we don't
prosecute the cat ideas are meaningful
and they they have consequences in the
world but they don't have bodies
Angels and Demons which I happen to
believe exist as have most people
throughout all of human history but some
doubt it today but Angels and Demons
are real they have metaphysical reality
but they don't they don't have bodies
only in man do you see that Nexus
perfectly in the Incarnation and in the
Blessed Sacrament so that
that
representation more accurately describes
what is really going on in reality even
even if in order to make calculations we
accept the the premise that the Earth
revolves around the Sun and the sun is
in the Galaxy or whatever
that's fine but that is a representation
too that's just a picture in your head
so that you can
make models and make certain
calculations this is a point that is
really driven home by Owen Barfield who
you'll hear a lot of us on daily wire
bring up this writer a lot he's the guy
who was instrumental in converting C.S
Lewis to Christianity really really
brilliant philosopher and he just points
out that in in the world
what what we take in
uh about the world around us
is necessarily just representations
right I'm not I'm not really seeing the
camera as the camera I'm
taking in the the information that the
camera has in itself and then I am
perceiving that and then I'm creating a
concept of that in my mind and we hope
that that records as well as it can to
reality uh but it is a distinct thing
and what modern science does is it it
separates the the
representations it separates the
phenomena from what the phenomena really
mean and it creates a sort of idolatry
out of that so that's why we think of
the human body now as just a bag of
chemicals
we don't think of it as a meaningful
thing with a soul because that's the way
science has to treat the body we think
of of therefore the cosmos in that same
way but there is more to the cosmos than
than just the physical world there's the
metaphysical world as well we all know
that we have to know that we have to
accept that that's the only way that we
can talk that's the only way that our
ideas can have meaning that's the only
way we can have hopes and joys and loves
uh and and all the rest of the things
that we can't quite touch
so that's
a long-winded version of that view and
it's it's why it's kind of like that
bell curve you know for for IQ it's like
a really dumb guy would say I heard the
man's the center of the universe heard
that they're and then the guy in the
middle would say well actually you know
the Earth is in this galaxy you're in
the super close door and I don't know
man and then you get to the top of the
bell curve and it's just the sort of
Jedi Knight is saying actually man
really is the center of the universe
that's that's I think what's going on
when we talk about our representations
of science all right next question
hey there Mr Michael this is Stanley
again thank you for taking my original
question on your pronunciation of words
like divisive versus divisive I was
listening to your show and Ben also
brought it up on his show the Canadian
new laws that work and to try to help
with assisted suicide now I think the
reason the Canadians are actually doing
this as well as other European countries
with socialized medicine is because of
their social programs
it's obviously much cheaper to just do
away with them than it is to treat them
for a fatal illness you might remember
several years ago I think back in 2018
there was a little boy named Alfie Evans
and he died and he may have died anyway
but he died because the British
government would not allow his parents
to seek treatment for him even outside
of the country even the Vatican was
going to send a jet to help him now I
think honestly at the core of all of
this is Satan he hates the family and he
does everything he can to circumvent it
from gender confusion to making husbands
and wives thinks that they're a drag on
each other to pornography and all sorts
of things anyway that's my perspective
what do you think
it's a great question sometimes people
ask questions like that at uh speaking
events that I go to you know they'll get
up and they'll say hey Michael and give
a dissertation on their their view of
the world and say what do you think of
that I agree actually I agree with that
that's a very good one and especially on
your first point when you say Do you
think that Canada now
is pushing assisted suicide because it
will save the money because they've got
these sort of socialist programs and the
answer is of course yes this is one of
the great hazards to socialized medicine
do all sorts of socialist programs and
getting all of your political power away
and upending all sorts of traditions
because uh you just get perverse
incentives
and conservatives understand that
incentives motivate people's behavior
so if the government is going to create
an incentive
for granny maybe to
leave this planet a little sooner then
you're going to see more of that
behavior okay and we know that because
part of the debate over socialized
medicine and Obamacare and all the rest
of it was that people spend
a huge proportion of the money that they
will spend over their whole lives on
Health Care in the final 18 months of
their life
right it's not as though you spend the
same amount every year on Healthcare
it's that you spend basically nothing on
health care for most of your life and
then a little bit more as you get older
and then at the very end you spend a ton
of money so if you're some technocrat
with a green visor crunching the numbers
you say wow if we want to save who knows
50 on our medical expenses in the
government if we just kill Granny 18
months sooner
you're going to get that behavior that's
a huge moral hazard next question
hey Michael it's Camille
um I have another dating question for
you so I recently had an X let's call it
a situationship because we weren't fully
dating
um reach out to me asking me to set him
up with one of my friends I was shocked
livid and fuming at this request but I
wanted to call in and see what your
thoughts were he was kind of a jerk to
me and things didn't end super well and
it's been a long time but I never
thought we were friends and I think it's
absolutely insane that he asked me to do
this we'd love to hear your thoughts
thanks Camille I want you to I want you
to take out your phone right now
all
I'll give you okay you got it you pulled
over you took out your phone I want you
to go to your contacts
actually it's probably easier just go to
your texts
okay pull up this guy's number
and go to gonna go to information about
and then delete the number Camille what
is wrong with you
good grief
you've written into the show before
about your relationship problems
don't what are you doing why do you talk
to this guy not only I'm sorry before
you delete the number block the number
and then delete the number out of your
phone so that you don't text him yeah of
course this guy's a total jerk loser you
don't need to speak to him ever again
what even when you say I didn't even
think we were friends after we broke up
well if you're not friends then delete
the number and block it Camille good
grief
ah Camille I just want to shake I just
want to reach from the camera and shake
you of course stop it stop talking to
these jerks all right next question
hey Michael I'm just wondering what your
view on recycling is because a friend of
mine a conservative friend of mine
recently made fun of me and was calling
me liberal because I was Recycling and I
like to recycle so I guess I'm just
wondering if you think it actually does
something and it could actually help our
planet or if it's another I don't know
fake narrative that liberals push also I
gotta let you know that I am a religious
Jew but I will still choose your show
over Benz any day thanks so much Michael
now we're talking all right thank you
clearly have marvelous taste that that's
so clear I could tell from the inside of
your question and uh the final part just
confirms it for me
um
the problem with recycling is that
it's a good thing to do in theory and it
doesn't really do very much in practice
a very very tiny proportion of the
things that we put in the recycling bin
actually end up being recycled in any
way and this is in part because it
involves not just Americans going and
doing their part but then we ship it
overseas to third world countries and
they're supposed to deal with our trash
for us and then often that doesn't
really happen and so it's a good thing
to do in theory I I I know that there is
a conservative perspective that says
who cares about the planet I'm just
going to throw my refuse into the ocean
and Burn Tires all day long and uh you
know that's my right as an American I
don't think that's true I think it's
very conservative to conserve things and
to be a good Steward of your environment
to be moderate in that regard uh the
problem with recycling is just
it doesn't really work so it ends up
being a kind of meaningless ritual so
do it don't do it it's not really going
to have much of an effect in the world
but I think your your instinct to be a
good Steward of your created environment
I think is is a good one and a
conservative one rest of the show
continues now because of the most
fascinating broadcast ever in the
history of Television yesterday and us
taking some time to go through Kanye I
didn't get to a few stories I wanted to
get to
we have to get to them though because
politically they matter a lot so uh make
sure you head on over to the member
block we also have fake headlines I need
your help in in Discerning which
headlines are real so if you are not a
member click the link in that
description and join us
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]